all right we are speaking with lola
brooks she is currently the
president of the clark county school
district board of trustees
her seat is district e and she is
running
once again for the seat this is the
second time you're running
and talk to me about why did you want to
run
again i think that this election cycle
is very interesting because there are
four seats that are up for election and
three of us
are termed out and i didn't feel that
leaving a majority of the board as
inexperienced incoming board members
would be good
i felt it would be a loss of
institutional knowledge and i felt that
the experience would be necessary to
help usher us through this process i
wanted to ask you about that
how do you think this election will
really change the makeup of the board
going forward
it's hard to say um i am always
optimistic
i think everybody brings a different
type of value
so i'm excited about that part i'm
excited to learn
what the different things are that some
of the candidates bring
but it will be an adjustment period
because we do have some
long-term board members leaving the
board for you
what are the issues that are important
right now that you want constituents to
know
going into this election november 3rd
i think that people should be aware of
what the board does
as far as what our role is and then i
want to make sure that people take the
time to research candidates so that they
are
as prepared as possible to hit the
ground running in january as we're
possibly transitioning into
schools or improving distance education
or whatever that looks like
so experience really really matters this
election cycle
in other times when you're not in a
global pandemic
some other board members can counter
that but i don't know that that's going
to be possible this cycle
i know that's really something that your
platform is on you have the experience
you've been president for two years
in regards to the uncertainty going
forward we are in the middle
of distance education a lot of families
not a big
fan so and as you mentioned trying to
figure out that transition
how necessary is it for you to want to
continue being a part of that
as we move forward i think that
it's really interesting uh with my
background and how that ties into this
role because i actually work in a school
that was already blended learning and
they transitioned to distance education
so
i've seen some of those struggles from
like a technology point of view
and it's it's really frustrating i have
a 13 year old who's in eighth grade and
i
am experiencing the same exact problems
as parents
and i also sympathize with teachers
because i know this is a difficult
transition so
trying to find a balance between um
making sure our expectations
and we are forward thinking we're trying
to fix we're trying to find solutions
and making sure that we're also having
realistic expectations because this is
a really challenging time for everyone
do you think
adding new members can really help the
dynamic of the board because
we have seen over the summer there were
issues we had the special meeting
discussing
jarrah's employment with the district so
and we
did see some split opinion so how do you
think
this election may help either unify the
board or maybe continue on the same path
it's been on
i think it's possible the election can
serve as a unifying event
it really depends on who else is elected
and why they chose to run
if candidates are elected that are
primarily in it for publicity
or for you know
self self promotion then it's really
really hard because they
tend to enter the field and they want to
make an impact right away
and sometimes you need to take a step
back and learn what your role is before
you can truly make a difference
and it that's really going to be what
would cause a challenge but
i think everybody will be closely
watching and
because of that i think there will be a
tendency of
people to maybe model better behavior
from the get-go
who do you feel is running for the
publicity
i would never ever ever um
talk negatively about a fellow board
member or a candidate running for office
i don't think that's professional
in regards to you running critics may
say
that um there's been some intense
moments on the board and they've seen
you
seem to align more so with dr jara
than not so how do you respond to people
who may be worried that
you are too aligned with him and maybe
not
formulating your own opinions or
standing up for what you think should be
done
i am i've always been outspoken and i've
always been direct and honest
so dr jar when he does disappoint me he
does hear it
uh i do believe in making sure that you
provide feedback
to your employees at the end of the day
dr jarrah is one of my employees
and i would never want to publicly or
privately treat
my employee my only employee in a way
that
is negative or is not helpful and i
would never provide
criticism that is not meant to be
constructive
so i i think that there is a tendency
in the community for people to want to
see us as adversaries but we're actually
on the same team
we have the same goals and the key
is providing direct feedback and making
sure that people understand what you
expect of them
and helping them reach that because
that's
that's who i am as a leader is there
anything else you'd like to add just
about this race and the fact you are the
only incumbent that has actually been
very
interesting i i've never run for
re-election before so
i don't have anything compared to but it
is very strange being the only incumbent
as
there are three uh new people definitely
coming on board
i just want to make sure that the public
does a lot of research on candidates
and that the candidates that are
watching also do a lot of research as
far as what their roles are
and the expectations so that they can be
better prepared and equipped for the
role
come january and lastly distance
education i know a lot
of parents may be thinking about that as
they go into the polls
where do you want to see that going i
know right now there are discussions
happening behind the scenes
so if you can maybe give parents any
insight about
any hope what may be going on and your
viewpoint on it
i think that there are lots of people
struggling with distance education
um i my family is one of them and we
should definitely
try to work out the kinks that they're
experiencing as soon as possible
our priority is health and community
health but we can't
we can't sacrifice the mental health and
the um i just don't know how sustainable
distance education is long term so we
have to
make some improvements so that we can we
can see it
last longer but we also have to be
willing to talk about transition
planning because some
some students are not going to be
successful in this environment
which we're starting to see already yes
right anything else you'd like to add
no i am good uh thank you for the invite
i appreciate it